[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's happening ship whooshing man
and this was in my pocket right now I
just bought this Marta the other day we
can't fit that much cash in it keep the
cash in one pocket and put the wallet in
my backpack I definitely got the phone
all right obviously everybody knew their
prime another phone in my pocket because
everybody needs another phone
my name is Jimmy Simpson and and this is
what I have in my pockets I have eaten
protein bar its nutrition on-the-go my
neon green headphones you will not find
me without these somewhere on my body
normally in the ear holes this phone has
all the essentials on it the music you
notice my family phones or if you you
got me you got me this is like the phone
were like I ain't talked to you in a
couple of years that's what's in my
pocket I don't have any pockets
spits much we gonna be about his pocket
this little red lighter I bought this
the other day see I will have pockets
cuz he just holds everything I need I
have a passport for international travel
120 cases get you a few beers a few
tacos I think I've got Steve Shelly's
business card jover for shocked you i am
la keith Stanfill phone it's been too
much there's are some aquaphor because
you never know when you're gonna need
more that's not a commercial I'm Harper
Penn on planes it's just set up with an
iPad and a good amount of weed
stogies got to quit kids don't do this
it's very bad
[Music]